[Music]
are you aware that olivia is in love
with your boyfriend she's mine we stop
Penelope damn
Miguel Olivia let's get this party
started tight garden truth what are your
intentions with our suite Olivia I
needed to find someone with friends that
I could trick into coming here I could
tell Olivia was an easy target I brought
you all up here cuz I'm okay with
strangers dying if it means I get to
live what the hell
games will okay wherever you go whatever
you do it'll find you okay something
really weird has been going on ever
since Mexico oh come on I'm seeing
things truth all right there
there I know it sounds insane Justin
this fine young lady here dared me to
show you my business Carter said tell
the truth or you die do the dare or you
die refuse the plate you don't screw
this you die
we're not playing the game
it's playing us so what do we do only
choose truth wait I'm sorry touch me
again and I'll break that hand truth
that's not how this works only game
decides honey break Olivia's hand you
have to do it because pissed as I am at
you right now there's no way I'm gonna
break your hand you don't really have a
choice
God just do it this game is too smart
half the people in this photo are now
dead we need to find what started all
this
do we get out of this game alive
you can't it's on the ends when all the
players are dead baby returns next dare
me to choose one of you to kill truth or
dare
[Music]